[Music]
Groucho Chopra Nick Jonas have just gone
public with their romance I love the
idea of getting married I totally want
to get married at some point those words
have got to be pretty sweet for Nick
especially considering just two weeks
ago Priyanka said this how about we all
starve until we get married because
that's the end of our lives anyway why I
said that was think about it every fairy
tale ends at the princess getting
married to the prince what happens to
her life after that so the idea is oh my
god she found her friends and now her
life is done most people's life start
after they get married and that's how it
should be so that's what I was taking a
take on I'm like stop telling women and
the ultimate goal in their life is to
find a guy and get married no doubt
Priyanka strength is just one thing Nick
loved each he was exclusively with a 35
year old at the Saks Fifth Avenue
Hamptons event with vogue vogue Saks and
me perfect now she didn't want to talk
specifically about her Joe bro but it
was crystal clear she's in a very happy
place what's the most romantic thing
someone's ever done for you oh I've been
lucky in that department I think it's
the it's the written word that always
makes me really happy like something
written down a letter or no do not ever
get me chocolates and flowers
[Music]
Priyanka's birthday is next Wednesday we
do a little digging on what she wants
yeah you're welcome Nick my birthday
wish this year would be what it is every
year for like the next year to be even
better than it was last one what I'm
doing for our birthday is I'm going for
a secret getaway big breath and now that
quantico has come to an end Priyanka can
concentrate on the big screen next up a
comedy isn't it romantic co-starring
rebel Wilson and Liam Hemsworth is set
to open on Valentine's Day next year
[Music]
[Applause]